there was questioning but it wasn't
allowed you're automatically put into
antivaxer Flat Earth crazy white
right-wing conspiracy theorist Kimmel
had been attacking Aaron Rogers for
years uh calling him a dingbat and an
antivaxer and he didn't want to get the
covid vax and everything else so here is
Aaron roders on Joe Rogan this is a
couple months back on what it was like
to be attacked for being a conspiracy
theorist wouldn't get backed science
that can't be questions isn't isn't
science anymore it's propaganda right
and that was my problem with the whole
thing
is science is propagated by peer review
yes and you have an idea and then giving
it to your colleagues or a study group
or an institution and then having them
review it yes and figure out do you make
any sense or there some holes in it yeah
right but there wasn't any questioning
of the information that was put out was
it it wasn't allowed there was
questioning but it wasn't allowed you're
automatically put into antivaxer Flat
Earth crazy white right-wing conspiracy
theorist that's what I said when I made
that video to Neil Young when when Neil
Young was getting all his music removed
from Spotify because I was promoting
misinformation I said what you say is
misinformation today is not going to be
misinformation in the future you have to
understand that and I was saying how
they were saying there was
misinformation well the things that you
were getting kicked off of social media
platforms initially you were saying that
masks don't work or saying that the
vaccine uh might uh won't stop trans
won't stop transmission or by saying
that the virus came from a lab all those
things would get you kicked off of
social media initially those have all
been proven to be true not only well not
the the VAC not the virus coming from a
lab that's just most people believe it
to be true assumed yeah it's it's like a
a large swath of scientific Community is
behind that now and including Newsweek
it was on the cover of Newsweek this lab
leak Theory which is not I mean it's the
most plausible scenario there's not a of
an animal host they haven't shown that
there's an animal host that could give
it to people this is not that's not
propaganda that's not fake that's not
pseudo science this is just what they
know all those things would get you
kicked off social media now they're
widely understand to be true so this is
one of the things that I said when I
made that video that these people that
you're talking about one of them Dr
Robert Malone he holds nine pat for the
creation of mRNA vaccine technology he
was a part of the creation of mRNA
vaccines he took the MRNA vaccine and
had a horrible reaction and almost
died right like we all get it anyone
that questioned the vaccines questioned
the mandates if you question anything
related to diversity equity and
inclusion all of these things they label
you these things the machine then puts
out comedians late night host they put
out television uh journalists quote
unquote journalists out there to label
everybody all of these awful things and
it just Marches
On